I don't care what happens to me I'm dead
already feed me to the pigs dude because
I could do a piranha tank yeah like they
could do a viewing where it's like they
dropped me in a piranha tank and then
everyone watches the piranhas and clean
me up like a [__]
have you guys heard of water cremation
sounds dumb oh like a toilet paper what
you know you just you put the toilet
paper in the water and dissolves you
like that
yeah
oh no I thought
I thought you should no no that's like
one of those water [__] jet machines
and you [__] disintegrated
[__] oh yeah yeah basically oh
is it like being in a hydro massage and
they take the plastic off and they turn
it all the way up yeah but when the
massage is done you're just bones you're
just at Planet Fitness screaming so do
people just turn into [__] sludge
it's not if sludge makes it sound so
horrible they turn into the dumpling
fillings so it looks like a giant dry
cleaning machine can we talk about water
wow
but wide water so you could flush it did
you guys have one of those at your at
your parents place yeah we were just
cremating people nothing right oh that's
weird and that's a weird machine so this
is a it's technically an eco-friendly
burial alternative that is now actually
going to be offered in the UK at like
one of the biggest funeral care
providers what was uneco about the fire
method is it because of the smoke and
smoke energy usage and just the
eco-friendliness like it apparently
water cremation uses I think three times
less energy but where does the Parks go
this is not of God yeah yeah all right
so what information also known as Aqua
Mission reservation and alkaline
hydrolysis or whatever uses water to
bring the body back to the skeletal
Remains the body is placed in a steel
vessel filled with water and an alkaline
solution it's then heated up which takes
the flesh back to its chemical
components amino acids peptides uh
sugars and salts oh so it fully breaks
it down so it's after about three to
four hours only the bones remain and
then they're then ground down to a white
powder placing an urn and given to the
family wow so it's like really efficient
so it just comes out a skeleton it's
like body and then it comes out
skeletons yeah and you gotta put the
skeleton in the [__] skeleton grinder
yeah yeah it's like a pulverizer thing
right whoa like it's a power wash and
then a pulverizing kind of as soon as it
takes longer huh well it says uh quote
for decades there have been just two
main choices when it comes to people's
end-of-life Arrangements burial and
cremation uh we'll be providing people
with another option for how they want to
leave this world because this natural
process uses water not fire making it
gentler on the body and Kinder on the
environment gentler I bet that's the
premium I don't know about that dude
that's the premium price point I think
fire is pretty gentle
well do you guys know how you guys would
want to go out there but what about the
urns if you get this and you open the
urn you want to smell the ash it's not
going to have that nice little smoky all
day no smoke you have to add artificial
smoke to it yeah
I want that Lucille's barbecue smell
yeah I love that smell yeah because it's
just grounded bones is that what you get
yeah
chalk
that's where you dropped the line
otherwise it's hmm
that fresh roasted Aroma Hickory and
body Hickory Hickory well it says that
around 245 kilograms of carbon emissions
are generated by one traditional
cremation oh look at the smoke the
equivalent of charging your smartphone
over 29 000 times on one of these
metrics traditional burials also have
negative environmental consequences the
chemicals used in the embalming process
can leak out and pollute the surrounding
soil and waterways who the [__]
embalming is that is that standard
practice when you get burial I think
they they do that to preserve to do the
viewing yeah but that's not the Target
demographic the Target demographic is
trying to get the fire people to the
water people yeah yeah Avatar last
Nation to water Nation yeah embalming
anyways they already don't they're
moving generally they're just offering a
third you know process now instead of
just the regular burials and fire
cremation I don't care what happens to
me I'm dead already yeah let the family
deal with feed me to the pigs dude yeah
so that if they because I could do a
piranha tank like they could do a
viewing where it's like they dropped me
in a piranha tank and then everyone
watches the Piranhas [__] clean me up
like a [__] so what's the like
so now we have if you're just buried
that's Earth that's even more like water
and fire what's the wind the air one
yeah well that's still got to be like
fire then you just blow yourself throw
you into a fan maybe you're just in an
air fryer or they throw you into a
[__] 747 you know one of those the
air turbine things yeah just while
you're in there they throw you in the
engine yeah which one is air yeah they
don't have it yet or they just throw you
out of a plane or they [__] connect
you to one of those giant helium balloon
things and just wait till your whole
body [__] pops oh that's tight yeah
dude that's a good way to is it is it a
good way to go or or water because you'd
have to break the Earth's orbit or they
just leave you in a desert oh dry up or
like those beef jerky machines oh you
get eaten yay turn your jerky what kind
of jerky flavor would you want to be
Teriyaki dude alien jerky dude alien
jerk smoked jalapeno for me who's here
on cremation versus burial I think I
want to be cremated I want to be I don't
really give a [__] to be honest yeah I
let my family decide I want to be buried
for this the case that maybe in the
future I can come out
oh oh oh you know what yeah because we
get cremated there's no shop I would say
even though there's a wizard in the
future cover me in Terracotta clay
and then make a statue and put you in
the bottom of the ocean nah like [__]
put me on a
in a statue and at the at the at the
movie theater next to Maine
[Laughter]
the one where the Boba time is yeah I
feel like if you're cremated that's it
you're done no soul nothing really
buried I feel like your Soul's still in
the earth oh okay kick it next to your
grave the whole time so you think all
the people that are cremated are just
erased that's it it's just like sleeping
black that's it no memory nothing well
what about the water people are they no
they're fishes oh yeah oh that's how it
makes sense
so the Earth people become earthworms
the Earth people
but the Earth people are still getting
eaten up by the Earth then we're ants
yeah Anthony turn into ants what don't
you understand about this you're right I
don't know where I'm going with this I
don't know where I'm going so what about
the wind people what do they become lots
of birds
[__] up birds
if I do get if I do get buried put me in
a driver's seat like that in my truck
and bury the whole truck Egyptian the
whole truck Egyptian yeah like you know
how they were in their tomb and then
they would be buried like with their
Chariot with their [__] hoes with
like servants like I want to be like
Emperor style yeah the whole Squad yeah
it's selfish just get like a hundred
people lock them in the Tomb with me
damn
and then uh
uh leave me some [__] Chinese money
you know the [__] you know the bird like
they burn that [__] for their ancestors
yep maybe a car yeah dude hook me up
with that leave me in there with a
Tacoma
um I think that'll be pretty cool gun on
my lap yeah because the afterlife I need
my knee to protect me I think you would
get grave robbed instantly
oh yeah look over there it is a [__]
sick Tacoma underneath
that's what they did back in the day
just a guy with a metal detector they
buried the Pharaohs with the Chariots
and the [__] canoes and they all got
dug up yeah dude you'll get you'll get
exhumed yeah you'll be in a museum
somewhere that'll be cool I want to go
to the Terracotta [__] uh Warrior
thing how many of them are there
thousands two thousand that's pretty
crazy you know I seen one at a museum
and I was like damn that's crazy this
guy is ancient as hell but he just looks
like a Chinese Uncle Dude who's a
Chinese guy but they also took him away
from all of his homies they put him in a
[__] Museum but when you see the
picture of the whole thing it's like
yeah and then they personalized every
single one it's jet Lee's army every
single one it's not like they had a mold
and they just made a hella it was like
Artisans made it look like the soldier
that's [__] crazy yeah it's like one
had a [__] [__] eye the other one had
a [__] weird nose it's like
but that's like the artist not doing
well I didn't look like that when I was
alive yeah
that's a lot of [__] soldiers I like
the idea of becoming space dust that's
pretty cool
space does it'd be like what's his face
in Guardians of the Galaxy when they
like eject you out yeah exactly is that
a spoiler dude yes Guardians of the
Galaxy full movie number two who do they
eject in this what's his name the blue
guy yeah yeah the whistling blue he dies
shut up are you serious that's number
two dog
in space
I'm sure because I'm wondering if like
oh you fall apart just 100 there's no
gravity pulls you apart don't you just
like freeze up and [__] no that's movies
like you're if you're like your eyeball
starts separating like you're [__]
because everything is held together by
gravity there is no gravity so like
everything the way that you think your
body is is just starts disintegrating
there's nothing keeping your body
together except the astronaut suit that
you're dead in Oh I thought he was gonna
be sent just to just this body yeah yeah
dude because it's like so cold in space
that it's just you just petrify
yeah you're gonna split dude yeah dude
you're gonna your eyeball is gonna fall
out does no gravity Joe doesn't know how
crappy Works what dude you wish you'd
never been in space never died in space
before
[Music]